[Musique]
et
il y a un an vous mais lisier à la tête
de notre famille politique
les objectifs étaient clairs rassembler
notre famille
la remettre au travail mais aussi
renouer avec les victoires électorales
c'est ce que nous avons fait avec la
formidable victoire des élections
municipales mais aussi avec les
élections législatives partielles
et puis avec les sénatoriales et demain
j'en suis certain avec les
départementales et les régionales mais
travailler sur le fond et est
essentielle parce que on reconstruira la
droite à partir des idées à partir des
projets c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu
lancer une douzaine de forums nous avons
beaucoup travaillé plus d'une centaine
de réunions ont été tenues
un rapport d'étape que vous avez tous
reçu vous a été présentée et maintenant
nous passons à un autre et à celles du
mois des idées ce mois des idées c'est
autour d'une centaine de propositions
très concrètes
nous vous consulterons afin que vous
puissiez réagir faire des propositions
soient contestés nos efforts soient les
challenges et soit au contraire nous
encourager à continuer afin de bâtir la
france de demain c'est notre objectif
nous travaillons pour cela et ce sera la
prochaine grande étape
[Musique]